if you're anything like me you google
some weird [ __ ] for example movies that
have included tinder twerking Pizza 2:00
p.m. Stockholm time to Pacific what are
Smarties in the US and your parents be
dependents on your insurance Erie Game
of Thrones shooting locations Adele most
popular songs Pompeii incinerated it
will NASA tell us if the world is ended
raspberry rhinoceros I'm gonna hit the
streets of Hollywood and make random
strangers read each other's Google
search histories do you google things a
lot I do I do Google a lot do you think
there's anything you could go that you'd
be embarrassed for other people to see
oh yeah yes I'm trying to think if I
search anything perverted yeah how much
beer you can take and not you know not
barter you know you know [ __ ] like that
would you be willing to let a random
stranger read your google search history
Oh God
oh yeah sure yeah oh yeah yeah 14 she LA
date ideas that girls will love did you
have a date I did have a date last night
a day and how they go I'm pretty well
when is Leif Eriksson day spongebob
today what's never never can visa
I was really some scripture and I
couldn't remember how to pronounce never
kanessa cut some trail mix it's awesome
how to get rid of the Rekluse when you
stand for countless amount of nights
here what is she wearing karaoke
perfect Ed Sheeran karaoke I was trying
to learn the song Victoria's Secret
Angel credit card [ __ ] I forgot the baby
food what does trippy mean
did you find all the tripping yeah I
forgot sister at Cass are you looking to
watch us distracting removing Lauryn
Hill with this Sister Act or Sister Act
- is it a crime to be naked in public
wanna be naked in public or were you
naked in public you know Allison sue
scaly was doing I was a connected
it involved somebody been Lincoln in
Parliament I wanted to know if Rosalie
Vaughn
what is critical race theory I still
don't know I took a test for pan-african
studies and I don't fit I didn't show up
the bus
what is club soda I think it's like
sparkling water you start there for
puppies what kind of puppies the bus
today
okay my favorite one so far is spicy
lingerie calm what it's sexy Red Riding
Hood costumes how discussed the
progression was Party City
Walmart Little Red Riding Hood and then
sexy Red Riding Hood lingerie Julie G
porn star
this is over I don't think only I'll
ever do that again it's cool to just
meet a total stranger take a little bit
of expense into your home life it was a
little nerve-wracking we did it we got
random people to read each other's
Google search histories I feel like I
learned a lot about the human condition
but I also have a lot of new questions
so it's on to Google for me
[Music]